the swedish company epicenter went viral
on friday when it publicized a new
technology that would implant a
microchip under your skin
to prove that you've taken the fouchy
algae
there are many lessons to take away from
this creepy turn of events first
ideas that began as wild crazy
conspiracy theories are morphing into
reality before our very eyes as we enter
into the third year of 15 days to slow
the spread
second
alex jones
is
a more reliable source of information
than about 97 of establishment news
outlets i know it's weird a lot of
people didn't expect it but just
when the frogs are gay or trans actually
and the microchips are in your skin
that's the way it is third
our political situation could get a lot
lot worse established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady in scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you can even get a
couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified distinction you
will be able to have land right next to
one another at one square foot and you
will both get to be called lord and lady
you can get this on your credit card on
your plane tickets you can even put it
on your dating profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
code knowledge to save an extra 10
today
i'm so glad that you liked that clip i
want you to be exposed to the entire
show and you can do that when you
subscribe ring that bell
you will get the notifications if you
don't get them here you can go to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knowles show never
miss an episode we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]